as a boy even I dreamed sometimes of
being our stack of Winterfell Bourdain
of Starfall legend has it that the
Dornish founder of house 10 followed a
falling star to where it hit the ground
and there he raised his castle
a fantastic story I know but House Dan
has a relic to prove it dawn the most
famous sword in Westeros forged from the
fallen stars called hat and a strong and
sharp is Valyrian steel many houses of
ancestral swords passed from father to
eldest son by my own families ice but
dawn doesn't pass the Lord of house day
and by rights to wield dawn a night of
their house was first be deemed worthy
it doesn't matter if he's the Lord a
younger brother or a distant cousin if
not have found to be worthy the blade
stays on the mantle in star fall until
the next generation
but dawn hasn't rested there often from
house Dayne have risen some of the
greatest warriors in Westeros Vorian din
who was a king and the greatest knight
in dawn before he was defeated by
Nymeria because of his honor and his
prowess she sent him to the wall in
golden fetters and took his heirs or
husband Joffrey did who answered Aegon
the conquerors demand to submit by
invading egg on Seven Kingdoms and
matching an army to the gates of Oldtown
where Aegon had been crowned the
greatest of them all so at the day the
sword of the morning during the reign of
the Mad King a band of outlaws calling
themselves the Kingswood Brotherhood
terrorized the forest outside of King's
Landing every force sent after them
either returned empty-handed or vanished
into the woods never to be seen again
the king was furious and dispatch there
Arthur of his own Kingsguard to deal
with the threat Sir Arthur didn't put
the villages to the question or set fire
to the woods to smoke out the
Brotherhood as other forces had done he
paid the small folk for the food his men
brought their grievances to the king
even won them the right to take a few of
the Kings deer during the autumn the
forest fire could look to the outlaws to
defend them but Sir Arthur did more for
them than the outlaws could ever hope to
do when a villager led Sir Arthur and
his knights to the outlaws secret camp
the Brotherhood to their credit didn't
flee one of their leaders the smiling
knight was a madman cruelty and honor
jumbled together for he didn't know fear
not even when Sir Arthur drew dawn
before him soon the outlaws long saw
that so many notches that Sir Arthur
stop to let him fetch a new one the
robber Knights chose another and then
asked for dawn Sir Arthur replied the
new shall have it the smiling Knight
never smiled again the mad fool dawn is
just a sword
Sir Arthur was the true steel strong
brave and loyal to a fault
he would never evaded rage as abduction
of my sister if his vows hadn't
compelled him and though we fought on
opposite sides I admired him when I was
younger I wanted to be him
every boy did and I killed him not in
single combat but as he was on his knees
a dagger in his back I'll never forget
the look in his eyes he wasn't angry or
betrayed he done his duty to the last
even though I found it dishonorable and
even though he knew what awaited me in
that Tower
sir Alfred and I'd the greatest Knights
who ever lived after Robert's coronation
I returned dawn to star for one day our
staying will raise aware these successes
to Sir Arthur until then
Don gathers dust above the fire with the
dream of every boy in Westeros